Salam alaikum guys how you doing I'm a
fraud be before we get into this week's
show when we show us a move for the
people and motivate them to start saying
what you got first let's start with the
arm James what's doing ok so my partners
has watch whatever guys were pushing
each other very common scenario and
fighting watch what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna do the old wax on wax off yeah I'm
just gonna do like this Grunk it alright
if you're the kid you guys are pretty
kid right a bit long 20 K so reveal it
locked up watch I'm gonna do that watch
son I'm gonna capture the risk let's see
that again
locked up or pushing each other wax on
capture the risk for drag the arm across
his body
and capture it with your left hand
okay so watch again I'm doing the wax on
wax off with my right hand I'm seeing
you stressed up to my left hand I'm
pulling his arm across pulling info for
us out beyond daddy's show don't go
anywhere be right back Salam alaikum
guys welcome back to the Deen show in
the Deen show studio for our hobby
assalamualaikum peace be with you how
are you breathe a cancer my brother